ce sont deux partenaires qui sont qui
sont historiquement déjà aidé par le
département soutenu par le département
ils sont très inventif ils sont réactifs
et je crois que c'est là qu'on voyait
vraiment la mise en oeuvre de
nozette des moyens qu'on pouvait leur
apporter c'est l'adn de caritas
on n'est pas là pour faire de la
distribution de doré on n'a pas une
épicerie on est vraiment dans ce que
vous appelez l'accompagnement des
familles en difficulté donc ça recouvre
énormément de de forme c'est d'abord
l'accueil c'est l'écoutent
c'est l'analyse des situations
individuelles qu'on est on est bien
au-delà de la seule assistance
alimentaire le social étant je dirais
notre compétence première notre adn ne
seront en première ligne comme boulot
dit et sans doute de bron nous vous
travers
l'évolution de la collectivité en
collectivités européennes être encore
plus attentif et peut-être plus réactif
aux problèmes qui vous sont posées
les associations demandent commencent à
demander plus de nourriture surtout du
côté frais donne aussi un nombre de
bénéficiaires qui était en une
augmentation légère pour le moment la
banque alimentaire c'était encore ya en
2010 à 2800 tonnes de produits
distribués delà de la ramasse ce qu'on
peut dire dans les magasins du duo g
on a commencé à trouver des produits sur
le marché spéciaux qui sont et qui ont
été donnés par des différents ministères
nous avons eu un soutien particulier au
niveau du département
en ce qui concerne les investissements
ou pas le sommes et
le département a toujours été derrière
nous ça c'est clair tous les ans sur
2020 ce sont deux millions trois
supplémentaires qui ont été mis qui ont
été mises en place
un million par l'état 1 million ou par
le département pour pouvoir lutter
contre la précarité et la pauvreté s'est
inscrit donc dans le dans un
dans un plan dans une convention qui a
été signée par le département et l'état
sur trois ans et donc pendant les trois
ans à venir nous allons mettre des
moyens importants pour pouvoir faire
face à cette problématique qui devient
malheureusement malheureusement
récurrente